は）こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
ま）まさき取締役と
キ）みなさんどうもキサでございます
は）まあキサさんは何といっても
は）特殊メイクのYouTuberですよね
キ）そぉーですねはい
は）白目のメイクとか
は）東京喰種の顔とか
は）ほんとにテクニシャンなんですよ
ま）すごい
は）うまい…っ(ﾁﾗｯ
キ）ｍ…まぁまぁ///
みんな）www
は）特殊メイクがすごい上手なので、
は）のっぺらぼうメイクって作れますかって聞いてみたんですよ
は）今回はキサさんに
は）まさきをのっぺらぼうにしてもらって
ま）ひさしぶり
は）久しぶりに会って
は）あ～わぁ～久しぶりぃ～
は）みたいにいったら
は）のっぺらぼうだったみたいな
ま）うっふっふｗこわｗ
は）おいらが行っても、もう
は）なんかしてくるなってバレてるんで
は）逆に、まさきでドッキリを仕掛けてみようかと思います
ﾄｩｷｭﾄｩﾝ
というわけでkisaさんありがとうございます！完成しましたああ！
はい、というわけで
これからターゲットが来るんですけども、
ちょっと怖い雰囲気で
部屋をちょっと暗くしといて、何気なくまさきをポッと置いといて
バッと振り返ったらのっぺらぼうだったっていう
怖いよね？　驚かしてみようと思います！
セッティング！
ま）ねえ、あれってさどこで撮ってんの？
は）ね、分かんない
ま）へえ…
ま）なんかしてる？///
は）なんにもwww
うわ！！！！！h
は）飲める？
ま）うん///
は）美味い？
wwwwww